et
[Musique]
le marin shadoks a décidé d'alléger les
gy be en bateau à travers l'espace pour
subtiliser leurs fusées ils mettaient la
dernière main à une caravelle
interstellaire de sa conception et il se
dépêchait de peindre tout ce qu'il
pouvait car disent-ils dans la marine
c'est un principe il faut saluer tout ce
qui bouge et peindre le reste jour du
départ de grandes réjouissances avait
été organisée et quand la shadoks
caravelle fut inaugurée on veut sortir
du goût loupé quelques intrépides de
shadocks qui furent invités à ramé est
il parti
[Musique]
puis aussitôt après sans perte de temps
inutile procéda à une autre inauguration
celle d'une magnifique statue où on
pouvait lire anneaux hardy marins perdus
dans le cosmos parce qu'on savait déjà
qu'il ne reviendrait pas mais ces
malheureuses bêtes
elle n'en savait rien et se préserver
les séparent cuir c'était justement pour
s'en débarrasser car de long il n'y en
avait pas tellement
et au bout d'un certain moment nous elle
s'arrêtait après quoi il n'y avait plus
rien sauf évidemment le néant
[Musique]